people joining me now is Dr Vivek
Trivedi the co-chair of the bmas junior
doctors committee Dr Vivek thank you so
much for talking to us so have you
received that letter
um and are you going to meet Mr Buckley
next week
yes we've had correspondence from Mr
Barclay's office and we're in the
process of setting up a meeting uh early
the the early the better because like
most people in this country we want to
work towards bringing this dispute to an
end as quick as possible
so that does that mean that Junior
doctors will no longer be striking at
all because you have this negotiation
planned
so at the moment we haven't called for
any further strike action we're going
into this meeting uh openly with good
faith and we hope that Mr Barkley also
does the same and in fact we've been
writing to him for for over uh from for
months over 150 days we've first written
to him so although it's sad that it's
taken so long for him to to respond to
hopefully coming to meeting will talk we
of course welcome it because that's been
our position this whole time if it seems
that he is coming in bad faith or is not
prepared to work towards a credible
offer that we can put to our members
then we do reserve the right to call for
further industrial action what would
that mean to you if he came to those
talks in bad faith what would that
represent so so you know I mentioned
we've written to him for so long and had
virtually no response from him for him
to initially uh reply to us on the
Friday before our strikes asking for us
to call off the strikes without an offer
on the table and previously with no
mandate to negotiate that's that's bad
faith he's just trying to kick the can
down the road and what we want to do is
we want to be able to put an offer to
our members that our members will be
happy with ultimately so that we can
bring this dispute to an end uh so
[Music]
has he made an offer no
so why are you agreeing to talks now
because so we've been open to talk the
whole time actually we we want because
we want to be able to work towards an
offer and we hope that by entering into
these talks we do get an offer to take
to our members to that they'll be happy
with so what's changed between now and
then why are you saying now yeah let's
talk
well that's exactly it it's not us
that's changed it's Mr Barkley we've
been open to talk this whole time but
now he's ready so we were we were ready
to enter talks before we're ready to
enter talks now and we'll be ready to
enter talks in the future but it's Mr
Barkley that's been stalling us this
whole time given that we've had this
fresh offer for nurses and ambulance
workers are you optimistic now that
Junior doctors are also going to be
given a deal
it's positive that the the other unions
of Mr Barkley have been able to have
talks it was obviously not in my not in
my position to talk on uh what those
members should do that's that's up to
them for their votes I do hope uh that
we can work towards an arrangement of
course unions have had a health care
sectors have had varying levels of real
terms pay cuts so I hope that he brings
us something that will be acceptable to
our members let's talk about what what
you think will be acceptable to your
members because you're asking for a 35
pay raise aren't you do you think that's
reasonable and achievable
so we're asking for a 35 uplift and
that's only to restore our pay because
we've had our Pace slashed by more than
26 over the last 15 years so all we want
to do is to restore that to come back to
net neutral
um and do we think this is reasonable
achievable of course this is actually a
drop in the ocean for the government
this cost will this will cost them
roughly a billion pounds or so which is
less than 0.1 of their National budget
and what that actually translates to for
our from my doctor colleagues is a
Doctor Who's on 14 pounds an hour uh
they'll be on 19 pounds an hour so it's
not breaking the bank at all for the
government but it will help work towards
uh fixing this Workforce crisis that we
have to retain the doctors but they say
it's just not affordable
uh well of course it's affordable the
government can choose to spend money
where it wants to we've seen them spend
billions through uh covert 30 billions
or so on testing trades four billion or
so wasted on uh unusable PP that was
burnt so it's a political choice and
they want you to to think that they
can't afford it but ultimately it's the
government's decision to appropriately
fund a healthcare system and pay Fair
wages or be honest with the public about
the poor standards of care that come as
a result of underpayment to its workers
well as I said they say it's not
affordable 35 would you accept five
percent and a lump sum payment
uh that agreement would not be
acceptable to our members because we've
lost as I mentioned before on more than
26 real terms pay cut and all we're
looking to do is to restore that pay
restore that pay that's the Mandate that
was given to us by our ballot which was
unprecedented you know the doctors have
spoken they're angry and they want to
get this fixed